welcome to this video coverage form form
of round two of the silliest cap
currently Halden the US and San Luis we
have a very fighting round 23
interesting games a little bit tricky to
do it in the formative two brief ones 11
longer more longer coverage of one game
so I'm going to do three games and just
be brief about them but try to cover the
the main points let's start with
Nakamura Carlson I can well as playing
1.e4 and we get the Rue La Paz very much
to be expected however cards the third
move now is a surprise his main choice
here of course is a six playing um yeah
normally the brier variation along one
of the long main lines I place Knight f6
for the balloon but now he goes for g6
an interesting sideline that is some I
really am never been on the height of
fashion a move that has been played a
lot Bayern vasilis musleh former world
champion and an interesting choice black
the main idea is to play of the
fianchetto obviously and then maybe
knight to e7 and castles d6 this kind of
setup an interesting line osm like the
idea but what I never lie to my just to
show my personal view on this is this
variation where black must play Bishop
e7 and this sort of does not really fit
within things um but ok let's say this
is simply a different approach for white
Nakamura castles Bishop g7 C 3 or this
is very standard be 64 Bishop d7 this
position is some a well known when known
that can arise also via different move
all that's like a six on move three like
here a six oops asics bishop a 46 um
white can now keep the center attention
with a normal move like let's say rookie
want something like that or you can play
d5 and this is what I got more added
after this we transpose to a pawn
structure that is very well known from
the Kings Indian what has this pawn
wedge and black has the f5 counter
players to play h6 first you don't want
to play this right away yes this is a
terribly weak spot only six so H 693 f5
yeah black now gets in F 5 really
quickly in the Kings Indian yes to move
they have 69 then player 5 this is all a
bit a bit sped up now the problem
strategically speaking is that black
does not have a light squared Bishop
which sometimes can be a problem
especially if we consider let's say for
example me and look at look at this if
black now decides to play it in a
typically Kings Indian fashion closing
up the queenside at the King side with
f4 then the lack of the light squared
Bishop can be a big problem black will
advance here while play h3 and white
will try to block this attack on a light
square very often black needs the light
squared Bishop to break through and this
piece is not it's not on the board
anymore normally it is believed to be a
huge achievement for white to have this
Bishop traded so all this is
strategically very risky for black and
council is not closing the center and
the King side with f4 is playing c6
getting for counter play I guess this is
a is a wise choice especially
considering that if we look at this like
I'm were not captured black is a little
bit better in development he's got his
pieces out and he
has got this old post on the forum so
for this slightly weak bishop here bad
bishop and he has some compensation the
knight on d4 and he's got some active
possibility sometimes even be five comes
to mind or play on the sea farm in the
game and I come where I quickly went to
exchange this piece and I think this is
a very wise decision you cannot keep
this night on before all the time cards
now finds a very dynamic response to
that black also could have played
something and something less
enterprising here but this is a good
choice the idea is to put this night on
air for of this sleeve so the direct
idea is to take play Knight f4 so he
captured one default and now he takes a
five and at first you think oh well it's
not a fiver and what's night h5 may be a
mistake if black now recaptures with the
peace queen for example there is G for
coming and this is not really what what
you want this black note that this kind
of thing yeah leaves black and huge
travel the night if you move the night
IAM there is this funny moose and
blacker is an absolutely bad shape at
the end of all here if we continue this
to the end the d6 pawn is dropping this
all looks a terribly a shake here for
you consider the piece captures so what
was this idea you just play tonight f
form a very strong concept this idea
involves to put it on d3 very strong
square or after the white capture this
is not play but I came around now to
play rook f6 and rook g6 and this leads
to very strong initiative black
something that after let's say 94 group
g6g 3 look-see for something that is a
is simply very attractive
he's got those active pieces the rukon
c4 is also now activated but mainly it's
about those two Bishop can also come to
e5 so not a very attractive option and I
can we replace f 6 this is better I
think keeping keeping the position more
closed takes g3 and now the night gave a
check here we should also check 93 of
course this looks very obvious but it
has a big draw like 94 and not a big
drawback but this is a good move after
Knight takes takes takes Queen takes we
have a funny situation where the queen
is double attacking two pieces yeah
enter let's say King g7 queen bee to
look see for the position should be
about equal maybe wide is slightly
better due to this permit nothing
nothing great talents move a stronger
night h3 I think yeah and 95 intending
to get the Queen also into the into the
mix yeah now and I can whereas playing
precisely place Queen to be one that's a
nice little attacking g6 yeah black
needs to attend to that now we went
Queen to d3 the queen is not a very
attractive bloke ADA but it's better to
have something better than nothing and
the queen is also protecting important
things here here yeah now Carson went be
should be five yeah bishop if I it has a
very direct idea um and exactly the idea
that was played in the game it is
however very difficult for y to prevent
it and it's also difficult for black to
suggest anything else I'd show you what
happens and i canna play drug 81 and now
Bishop takes g3 was played funny
sacrifice after H takes crea h3 check
Kim Ji Won necessary if the sir
unlucky idea we we have a perpetual
checker and this happened in the game
yeah could could it be avoided I really
don't think so in this position we have
a situation where black has the
structural deficit with this double
pawns i mean the d4 pawn is weak and he
needs to find some compensation for that
and this can only be by attacking on the
king saud the strongest the ticking idea
is Bishop b5 getting this Bishop into
the into the game and why it has no
really really sensible idea to avoid it
otherwise and black the tech is getting
is too strong um let's say if why try
something like that just to also cover
g3 black antique and just trade things
let's say here and he's got this counter
play against see for something like this
is is totally equal um I think the game
as it went is a very correct draw it's
nothing nothing where you can blame any
player for not having any fighting
spirit I mean if you talk about modern
top players those two are probably the
biggest fighters around um so a draw
simply am probably the logical result of
the whole thing okay let's look at the
next game now and this is some kawana in
solid rock mvl at sea we have a chemicon
advanced this is in fact a slight
surprise because mashina graphs main
defense against 24 is the Sicilian
especially the night off and he's not a
very compelling known for playing the
caricom um a bit of a weird decision on
considering that koala is also an
excellent record with the advanced calc
on and is known to be very good to
theoretician m and then we get one of
the main lines Queen B 6 or C 5 and
Queen B 6 is probably the
sharpest response available to white set
up so on this what what what mvl is
doing is really a kind of show me
attitude yeah show me what you've got
prepared I am better prepared than you
this is a kind of a statement that this
move is making and kinda wanna quickly
dashes out his moves Knight c3 this is
some the absolute main line here and
there only critical move it leaves be to
hanging um like does not take it what
happens if he takes yeah after this
white has an interesting choice but the
main he can also play not be fire but
the the main point is is going to be one
which was a revelation when it was shown
first interesting idea black nor cannot
take the night this is losing the house
and in fact black is in slight trouble
already he can exchange and now White
has excellent compensation for the pawn
evil most of the time Black will play
see form and just give up the pawn on b7
something like that after let's say
these moves is terribly risky black has
nothing developed and white is getting
at blacks position quickly it's not lost
lost or anything but super dangerous
yeah 96 is what is played nowadays our
castle simply ignoring everything and
playing for development Queen B 2 and
Queen you won it looks a bit strange
maybe if you don't know the line but all
this has been played multiple times
there have been many games with this I
mean not like dozens but some Bishop to
b4 to this to set up the pin night b5
yeah getting those ideas in the game and
black is playing Bishop a 52 cover c7
look be one attacking the Queen it only
has one square capturing the porn white
is two pawns down
but it's clear that this position is is
extraordinarily sharp white has mostly
tried rugby three year I think only only
tried look be three auty koala plays a
different movie plays rook see one this
seems to be new queen b 2 and now G for
all this was quickly played and it's
clear when we all move 15 that this is
all part of coronas preparation g4 is of
course very very sharp weiter has a
dangerous initiative in any case even if
he play something like that which is not
the best move probably but even
something like that after night a form
leads to a dangerous initiative even
after the Queen Trinity or something
something like that is an excellent
position for wide I mean in terms of
compensation not in terms of like
winning immediately or something um it
is a very dangerous opening choice and I
really question of why should log rafts
choice him after g4 he sank into thought
and played Bishop to g6 um bishop g6
certainly looks like the only move but
it probably had to try to remember if he
had analyzed it before f4 was coming
quickly again kawana said he remembered
that he has analyzed it and thought it
was good but he couldn't remember
exactly how it how it went down but he
still decided to play it immediately to
him to irritate like a bit and just
trying to give the impression that okay
I know everything here what are you
doing um yeah and the big problem is to
defend this is absolutely difficult on
the computer wants to play or suggests
as an as an alternative 97 um this leads
to a total mess of course 96 can you
have 8 f 5 you see that bishop strap
this was the idea of f/4g form and black
can
in fact make a piece sacrifice out of it
something like that is in fact a very
interesting position and the playable
position it seems difficult to work out
over the board however this was
interesting I think however Bishop
before is not a bad move what was she
played but hey you know it costs time he
spent 50 minutes and come on has spent
nothing and even played Luke f2
immediately also note that while she was
taking its time that one I had time to
remember its analysis so this is very
useful so Luke f2 and yeah the idea
obviously to attack the Queen from the
side and threaten something like a
bishop f3 or Bishop d3 yeah it seems
that the next move that that mvl places
one night h6 is already losing its own
it's very difficult anyway to play White
has a strong initiative in any case um
yeah what is best here then my coat
gives Queen before after some time but
I'm not claiming I analyze this
extensively the position is simply super
complicated Queen f1 is a good reply
getting out of this pin and setting up
now finally this check and the CAPTCHA
only form and something like that for
example if we if we follow this this
line is quite clearly a dangerous attack
now you know this is ignored and it
seems that black cannot even take this
if he would take it yeah this is
disastrous check check coming Luke c7
coming and the capture here this is a
totally lost position amazingly like has
absolutely no defense something like
let's say here why takes takes you need
to give up the exchange Jack and
this is a devastating attack black Lexus
species yet those pieces are not in play
White's position is also open with the
king but there is no counter play a very
very dangerous position on O king of
eight another possibility wide will go
here Queen B form could before and now
something like this even with with
Queens traded it's just a very dangerous
for black white as dangerous nights he
cannot enter possibly with with his
pieces d7 c7.r squares at the moment
covered but this is obviously dangerous
for black and I think very unattractive
to play I mean I would never ever go for
this position it's gonna be honest
especially get someone who might even
have it prepared at home um yeah night
h6 is what he played but it seems that
he miscalculated to the upcoming
complications Bishop d3 now is is very
strong and yeah black only has screen
before it has no other square look to be
one yeah and now we see the big problem
where should the Queen go it went to see
five and after nine txt for we have a
sort of double attack the queen is a
checked and the bishop is attacked after
this screen a five white or ever
threatens 96 winning the Queen and this
means that black is losing a huge chunks
of material after Knight takes e4 what
black could do is to take on a one but
after night c5 takes takes this is also
a terrible position black cannot afford
to take here after this we have a double
threat against the night and 97 so he
has to play probably castles or King e7
really let's say castles yeah and then
white he's got nice selection here but
he can just
clay move like that asking this night
what it is doing on age six and then mop
up from the queenside terrible position
why does Winningham yeah he went for
this which is basically a piece down but
maybe he was hoping that he's got two
pawns and can maybe stay up some trouble
but there is simply nothing white only
now needs to be a little bit cautious
not blundering anything he's getting out
of this pin so that the night can move
and after some more moves III was lost
yea after in this this machine lagrave
resigned the game so an excellent start
for kawana his second win and mushy
lagrave with this loss he had didn't
have a very good style of this
tournament but i think it was really
questionable to play into this opening
that he um yeah it seems is not a super
expert in and he stumbled right into one
of kiwanis and preparations so um yeah
in a way it's a it's a case of putting
putting the hint into the lion's mouth
but also a little bit unlucky to to run
right after right into this this thing
after G for H F for this position is
super hard to defend in a practical game
okay so let's look at Aronian to pawn
off as our final game to cover we have
seven ankles laughs align that apart of
sometimes plays but not regularly so
couldn't really be expected by Aronian
um III b5 and c5 is an interesting
choice this line by aronian i think this
is a pretty interesting line for wide
the ideas with the c5 white is blocking
the Queen side we can continue a bit g6
before sorry before what white wants to
do is he wants to play a form
then try to open up the queenside very
often we have interesting situations
where I'm p sacrifice is possible on b5
if we to pull off now place a 5 but if
if black plays in a someone to somewhat
passive fashion let's say 97 for example
a for rugby a this is not good but just
to show you the point white very often
he won't even take right away but very
often he would later try to get a piece
sacrifice in on b5 to get those two
pawns at the end white would have B and
C porn before and c5 and these pawns
will be very dangerous in the end game
very often this is a game plan for white
the part of does not want the situation
here right away it goes for counter play
with a five very typical of his style is
not a kind of sidon wait player yeah
aronian that took them and here to paula
play interesting with 90 form which is
all this is Sir is new I think it
aronian said that it was it was still
known chairman but ok I'm always hard to
tell what what's true what's what's a
invention or what's uh what's the lie to
rehearse in those interviews ok 94 yeah
aronia now plays something really
extraordinarily he takes in place night
to g2g 5 that's a really a really
amazing choice the reason why this is so
um yeah so on so enterprising is the
move Queen d5 this night is hanging how
do you protect it yeah white actually
yeah only has a yeah he only has one
move to really justify his play and this
is f form this is what he did if he goes
h form instead then black can amongst
others um play play this and this cannot
be White's idea his whole center is
crumbling now
and the night on age three is simply
ridiculous um this cannot be the idea
what is that implied f form this might
look normal but has a very very big
problem let's see H 693 like ticks and
now black can't play Bishop takes the
form really a shocking development the
idea is of course if Y takes and of
course it must take an hour else there
is III and we have a discovered attack
on the rook so has Aronian blundered
here yeah I probably not he's taking
some some enormous risk here I guess
Bishop takes Queen takes Queen d2 so
let's a look at this White has given up
an exchange for one pawn it's got this
AP a five point after all and this is an
important point it's not like this can
be taken at any moment um white ear has
a very interesting position and
compensation if it's enough hmm I doubt
it and I think the players also had
their doubts in the press conference I
couldn't see this press conference
unfortunately but um I think I'm the
situation is very very difficult to
assess white also has the two bishops of
course that can be very dangerous here
there was a principal choice develop
late night a six which is probably okay
another idea was and this was probably
this probably would have been my choice
I think because I'm the Torah Slayer
frightened of things sometimes e six
would have been probably my choice to
make sure that d4 d5 is not happening
quickly um and then maybe queen d5 later
it's very tough to analyze this position
YTM may choose long castle so King f2
awesome um hard hard to say I mean white
has some compensation but is it enough
tough to say what he plata ever seems to
be okay he only is making a mistake
later long castles Queen to d5 and now
Bishop g2 everything else
the only move that make sense the check
King be one and here we come to the
first critical position of the game here
it seems that um tupolev definitely had
to play Queen before oops he played that
but he definitely had to play Queen
before check it seems after that I think
white is struggling to justify
compensation one key point is that after
King a 1 he has the yeah very strange
move Kingda 7 covering the the c6 poem
with the king after that I really
couldn't find anything sufficient for
white it's a it's still an unclear
somewhat unclear situation let's say d5
takes takes Knight c7 takes King see aid
but ultimately here I think black keeps
a keeps his position together and
probably would be on top still lots of
uncertainty in those lines but it was
better than the phone of choice he
played this d5 and now gave the check
the whole position is obviously very
sharp and can be easily um can be easily
and leading to a disaster for example if
black plays this movie I'm going to have
six Bishop before here for example is
exceptionally strong intending Bishop d4
and an innocent move like we never six
would lead you into huge trouble in d6
and whitey has a fantastic position this
is something that probably is losing c6
Hanks e7 Hanks and the long diagonal can
be can be fatal he played the check and
now after King be too I think the next
two moves really a spell is faid the
position is very very difficult to play
but still I think long castles simply
too risky the king is so exposed him
that it ultimately costs like maybe low
short castles was better
on it's difficult to get to get to the
truth of the position without spending
very long time it I think this is too
dangerous the depot now advances and
after the capture now the thing is
definitely lost I mean this is those two
moves were too much I looked at 95 here
and I wasn't totally sure about this
something like this looks a very very
dangerous and it is dangerous but I
wasn't really sure that this is okay
this is it's like a win for white white
is definitely better but i'm not sure if
it is an easy win blanks defensive ideas
to move the f porn and then give the
exchange back white is better here no
doubt but is he winning not totally
clear to me what's clear is in the game
after the capture and here the recapture
this this attack here on c6 on the on
the King side is too much black cannot
defend this gave this check King be ones
I check again you see one Queen f6 a
very important point is that are here
after Queen f6 is that if we look at an
alternate line here let's say let's say
black play something like c5 here Bishop
c6 Queen F 697 King c7 Bishop b5 here
there's a funny line like an even yeah
give all these checks here yeah and
white is still winning in this position
black and try to trade and now Bishop a5
is killing him the night is also is also
hanging something like this okay
something like that this is it's very
nice attacking and the mid threat very
funny line yeah in the game we had Queen
f6d seven check King b7 bishop d for
Queenie six Bishop h eight and two part
of resigned yeah completing his somewhat
disastrous start of this tournament he
certainly cannot be a very much
satisfied with this two losses and it
really didn't look didn't look didn't
look good he seems to be out of out of
shape somehow in this event um so after
two rounds we have kawana with two
points aronian with with the win one and
a half point and cancel nakum one fifty
percent we have cars and playing them
kawana in the third round so a very
essential game Carlton definitely will
try to win the game 22 to get near the
leader and even that even though the
kitchen with the win very important game
so let's look forward to that next round
coverage coming tomorrow thanks for
watching